vielleicht hat er anfang märz
mitbekommen der russische präsident
wladimir putin hat in seiner rede an die
nation eine ganze serie neuer
nuklearwaffen vorgestellt angefangen bei
raketen die mit 10 facher
schallgeschwindigkeit fliegen unbemannte
atom u boote und atomwaffen die jedes
gegnerische abwehr system überwinden
angeblich doch wie genau sollen putins
wunderwaffen funktionieren und was ist
wirklich dran an diesen russischen
rüstungsprojekten ein hoch brisantes
thema das ihr euch auf whatsapp
gewünscht habt danke dafür und herzlich
willkommen bei pixum science fiction wie
ihr täglich an die neuesten infos
aufkommt und bei klick zum mitmachen
können dass er vater am ende des videos
die rede vom russischen präsidenten fand
zwei wochen vor der russischen
präsidentenwahl statt und zeitweise
klang ist tatsächlich eher wie ein
science fiction beispielsweise als
wladimir putin die schwere
interkontinentalrakete hat einen
neuartigen torpedo sowie ein
marschflugkörper der atom betrieben ist
vorstellte an dieser stelle sehen die
zuschauer das video einer rakete die
rasend schnell aufsteigt dann folgt eine
computeranimation die zeigt wie der
marschflugkörper europa um runde den
atlantik in richtung süden hinter sich
lässt und dann über dem pazifik richtung
norden fliegt die botschaft dahinter ist
mehr als klar russland präsentiert einen
waffentyp der problemlos jeden ort auf
der erde erreicht und auch in der lage
ist die westküste der usa zu treffen
angetrieben mit nuklearenergie doch die
rakete wird russischen angaben zufolge
nicht nur mit atomenergie betrieben
sondern trägt zudem eine atomwaffe an
bord und das liebe leute das wäre
tatsächlich eine große sensation vor
allen dingen der antrieb denn atomkraft
liefert im vergleich zu anderen
antriebsarten sehr viel mehr energie pro
masse und somit wäre das grundproblem
des raketen ausgelöst denn bisher galt
um eine große reichweite zu erzielen ist
viel treibstoff notwendig doch der
wiederum reduziert die reichweite also
ein fliehendes ziel
ja aber das war es noch nicht mit putins
neuem waffenprogramm außerdem mit dabei
die hyperschall rakete kinosaal
übersetzt so viel wie durch den ausbau
des russischen
arsenals bezeichnete putin als reaktion
auf das verhalten der usa zitat es geht
um neue strategische raketensysteme
russlands die wir entwickelt haben als
reaktion auf den einseitigen ausstieg
der vereinigten staaten aus dem vertrag
über raketenabwehr und die de facto
stationierung solcher systeme auf dem
gebiet der vereinigten staaten und
außerhalb der amerikanischen grenzen so
putin
die ausdehnung der nato grenzen habe
russland gezwungen solch ein
verteidigungssystem aufzubauen all diese
waffen sind aus russland
funktionstüchtig eines der waffensysteme
sei bereits jetzt bei den truppen und
jederzeit bereit für einen kampfeinsatz
in einem interview mit einem
amerikanischen sender bestätigte
vladimir putin auch zu einem späteren
zeitpunkt noch einmal dass alle tests
erfolgreich verlaufen seien zudem gäbe
es keine abwehrsysteme weltweit die
gegen diese wunderwaffen an canon mit
den hyperschall waffen habe russland
beispielsweise enorme vorteile im
bewaffneten kampf und ein direkter
angriff auf sein land würde im übrigen
auch mit aller konsequenz beantwortet
werden fest steht jedenfalls mit seiner
rhetorik hat putin die ganze welt
aufhorchen lassen doch expertinnen und
netzwerken sind sich tatsächlich uneinig
darüber ob die präsentierten waffen wie
beschrieben funktionieren einige
forschungsgruppen bezweifeln gar die
existenz dieser russischen waffensysteme
andere coach ingo ist experte im bereich
militärtechnik und hat in einem
unabhängigen russischen fernsehsender zu
bedenken gegeben dass einiges in putins
rede zu aggressiv dargestellt wurde
vielmehr handelt es sich bei vielen
waffen um eine weiterentwicklung bereits
bestehender dazu coach ingo die
interkontinentalrakete salat ist eine
modernisierung einer rakete die in den
1970 er und 80 er jahren gebaut wurde
sie wird in denselben alten raketen
schächten stationiert werden
im vergleich zu amerikanischen
waffensystemen sei sie mit eingesetztem
flüssigtreibstoff sogar eher rückständig
das gezeigte video ist sogar zehn jahre
alt und wurde schon mal zur bebilderung
des vorgängermodells eingesetzt
bezüglich des atomgetriebenen
marschflugkörper schließt sich der
russische militärexperte der meinung
europäischer
raketen expertinnen und experten an die
grundsätzliche zweifel anmelden ein
marsch für körper mit einem kleinen
atomkraftwerk sag einfach viel zu schwer
um zu funktionieren zudem sei es bereits
in den 50er und 60er jahren sowohl von
den usa als auch von der sowjetunion
getestet worden
die ergebnisse waren ernüchternd auch
andere fachleute haben starke zweifel
denn wie soll solch eine rakete ohne
jahrelange umfangreiche tests zur
einsatzreife gebracht worden seien
deutsche test hätte man aufgrund der
radioaktivität absolut bemerken müssen
zudem sei ein weiteres problem technisch
wohl noch längst nicht gelöst wie soll
der atomreaktor während des fluges
gekühlt werden wo er doch durch die
vorbeiströmende luft und die damit
verbundene reibung sehr stark erhitzt
werde fragen über fragen
und bisher gibt es keine antworten wenn
er als erstes erfahren wollt wenn es
hier antworten gibt dann endet meine
telefonnummer hierbei whatsapp dann
erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen
vom neuesten video täglich garantiert
ihr könnt dort direkt über mich in der
redaktion von krieg zum mitmachen und
mitbestimmen was hier bei pixum passiert
und zur begrüßung gibt es ein kleines
geschenk von mir einfach hier
draufklicken wir natürlich nicht das awo
mit der genau glocke vergessen
und hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch
draufklicken 1000 raketen zum mars da
geht es um die friedliche nutzung von
raketentechnik ansonsten bis dann bleibt
an